All right. Let's look at the awareness level questions exercise here.
And I just want to set up the the premise for
this first before we dive into the example. So the premise
is that it each level of
awareness. Your prospect is asking different questions
based on their own knowledge based
on their understanding of you know,
whether or not they're aware of solutions, whether
they're completely unaware whether they know they
have a problem, you know, their own knowledge affects
the kind of questions that they ask
and if we know the kind of questions, they're asking that
allows us to answer them to build
trust to show that that we
are that there are product or our company
or our personality whatever your business
looks like, but we're the ones who can solve you can
solve their problems who can answer their questions and I
like to think of the the
scenario of if I was going to go to Google and do a
search based on a specific
product and I'm in each one of these different levels
of awareness. What would I enter into Google?
So let me just show you I walk through
an example here. So we've already talked about the air purifier in
one example
So we'll stick with that for a second but you
know this this here the prospect's
knowledge and the most aware that
this is obviously somebody who's who's gonna
buy your product. They're on your list. Most likely
they just haven't gotten around to it. So they're they're
knowledge. They're they're sort of their mindset is I'm
going to buy your air purifier.
And so the question they might be asking themselves is
you know, what's the least expensive air
purifier that does the best job so they
haven't gotten around to buy in your air purifier, and they
may just be doing a little bit of price comparison.
Somebody who is product aware, you know, I know
about air purifiers. They may
be asking questions like how much space can an air
purifier really clean. So they're trying to figure out like
is it worth it?
If somebody is more solution aware.
So here they know about your air purifier here. They
just know that there are air purifiers in
the world. And so they're they're aware
that the solution exists so they may be they're not
thinking about your product, but they may be thinking, you know,
if they're considering buying one eventually like hey, you
know is ultraviolet cleaning a better long-term way to
keep the air in my home clean.
So there might be comparing, you know, ultraviolet to a
HEPA filter or I don't know a
ton about air purifiers, but you know, they're kind of
comparing that the features and benefits of the solution, but just
because that's what they know. They don't know about yours yet.
Here under problem aware. You know, I know
I want to clean the air I breathe so that's
what they know.
So they're aware that their problem is their
breathing dirty air.
And so what they may be searching for on Google
or thinking about is, you know, I feel
congested at home, but not at work. So what's
going on so they may go to Google and be
like why why do I feel congested when I'm
at home, but I don't feel that way at work.
And so this will be a great opportunity for them to
come across an advertorial of yours answering this question
helping educate them on what what
the reasons might be for this this scenario.
There could be others here. I feel
I feel congested at home, but not
in my car.
Or I feel congested at work, but not at home.
Unaware so these are people that they
they're not really looking for
air purifiers. You know,
I'm sure that I don't know if this is a great example
for the air purifier example here, but
I suppose there are people who just don't
know about air purifiers or there's just
not in there there realm of awareness
here, but you know the
the the person who values the health.
of their family and the value their
health
those people do exist. And so
Here somebody who's completely
unaware of how your product could solve their problem or how
your product can add to their health?
One of the things they may be in they may be open to receiving a
message whether it's an ad. I don't know they really be out
searching on Google but you can think about this in terms of like
if you if you already know that somebody values their health,
you know exercise and health are important
to me besides doing cardio. How else can I improve my cardiovascular health
so you can see, you know
here if you're running an ad to top a funnel completely unaware
in your cylinder air purifier
You're not going out and say saying hey buy my air purifier.
You're saying if you or
somebody who values cardiovascular health?
Then I've got a little bit more information for you.
If you click through again, not really
trying to sell them. You're just more more or
less introducing yourself what you're
about maybe give them a free report.
You know kind of that that approach but
this is sort of a cool way.
I think to break down the different segments
of your market and the in the levels
of awareness and we we do this or
did this for breakthrough advertising too so
You were running Google ads break through advertising in and
so to think about how we're going to create Those
ads somebody who's
most aware. They already know about breaks or
advertising so they're gonna buy it. So if they were searching in
Google they may be saying how much is break advertising where
can I buy it?
Who has the cheapest price?
Can I get a PDF break prioritizing like these are all
things that people will be asking that they're in the most store category.
And specifically they they know about you know
Titans and that we have brick to advertising like they're on our list.
Somebody who knows about the book but not necessarily that doesn't
know that much about Titans.
They may be saying, you know gosh this
breaks for advertising worth the money.
Man, I wonder why is the book so expensive who
wrote it?
And once they find that out, well, who is this guy? Who's Eugene Schwartz? What
else did he write, you know, so they're educating themselves on
like is this a trustworthy product? So they're
answering these questions. So these are all opportunities for
us to to answer these
questions so that we can move people closer to be
in a place where they feel comfortable making a
purchase.
somebody who's solution aware
You know, they may not necessarily know about breakthrough advertising,
but they know that there are
people out there who teach copywriting so they
know the copywriting courses exist. So one
of the things that they may be searching for is I know
that there are people teaching copywriting. What are the best books to help me become
more persuasive in my marketing.
Who has the best copywriting course?
How can I learn what makes people buy what
are the best copywriting books, you know,
so these are
all ideas for how we could go out to the market in Google
ads. We could write articles and drive people to to
those articles that answer these kind of questions and build
some trust with the market
for problem aware. You know,
I know that I need to improve my copywriting so
I'm aware that I need to get better at writing copy
sales copy.
So then what they're thinking is, how can I become a better
copywriter? How does that happen?
So they're probably going to get introduced to these
Solutions over here.
All right, how can I become a better marketer?
How can I start a business on the side while working in
my day job?
All right. So these are all ways that they can come into
contact with the idea of improving
their copywriting skills.
And and these
are these are searches that we could show up for these are ads
that we can run.
Completely unaware they don't know anything about breakthrough advertising.
They're not even that familiar with the
idea of copywriting. Maybe they're just kind of marketers in
general. You know, they work in a a corporate
office in marketing to them is is a
brand and
billboards and things like that, you know awareness. So so
here their mindset is more like
I understand. I know that products don't just sell
themselves. I need good marketing. So that's
that's where they're coming from. Like I know that any marketing
of some some sort.
so
here, you know, I think a marketing is branding some kind of
setting the stage there for you.
So what can I do to improve my marketing skills?
And this is somebody they don't even know what copyright it
is.
so I may you know, put an article together of
What there are different types of marketing so I might need to introduce them
to direct response marketing versus, you know,
brand marketing or awareness building.
You know, how can I how can
I come up with marketing ideas?
I have an idea for a product and I want to start a
business. How do I sell a product?
and so
this this is such a helpful exercise to go
through and put yourself.
One just coming up with these questions here is incredibly
helpful because it forces you to
think like your your prospect and and
then once once you
kind of internalize that mindset then
you can go into.
Just dreaming up different questions that they would ask some of
these could overlap I suppose but this
is this is incredibly helpful just to
understand where your Market is
because if you ever want to sell them
anything, which I know you do. It starts
with understanding your Market better than anybody else
and that is that I'll just keep saying it that
is the truth and it break through advertising everything starts
with the market. So
This is this is how you use the
awareness level worksheet here and reach out
if you have any questions.